I'm actually kind of curious what you're
looking at in fact it was Odell oh yeah
what happened was he okay
yeah he looks like he's doing great
oh he's doing you know really we danced
together and I thought oh we film that
story maybe maybe this will be it maybe
I'll end up with an NFL football player
yeah maybe he'll date me and then he was
like Maggie is such a cool dancer you
remind me of my taxi oh that's not what
you want to hear it's not what you think
now the LEGO fans are gonna know that
Odell Beckham's not a great king well
you know he didn't like me he's like
that yeah yeah his dad asked me out
though Oh Joe senior yeah we were at the
bar well maybe he didn't really ask me
out he was just saying so what's able to
use it again maybe we'll sit with you
know that counts so cute of these dad
you know this is that cute this is so
much better than like any questions I
would have asked you know what I will
and when I get in a situation like that
what I'm nervous and I don't know what
to do I always I got to remind myself
because I forget I start to panic and I
have to remind myself to not panic but
then sometimes I forget to not panic are
you all right oh I don't I'm sorry if
you just need not attack I'm just gonna
tattoo no way you would always know I
was gonna give a damn because I never I
always think that I'm gonna finish it
how am I gonna it would have been
perfect remind myself never interviewed
snot kissing tattoo is that's so crazy
no I'm about to I'm going after you want
to go after this I'm going at lunch
perfect I'm doing it and I'm okay just
let me know when you're gonna get a
tattoo I'll get another one the same one
where'd you get that what's it to get
that out of New York
all right they'll pull New York where
did you want me to say
what part of New York if you say
Brooklyn it wasn't it was zoo's
Manhattan all right
I wasn't get a tattoo higher level oh
cool uh so the lego movie the lego movie
sequel I loves bird for sure by the way
definitely where's Bernie did you live
in Williamsburg oh yeah I lived in
bed-stuy and where do I mean it's it's
nice no Williamsburg but it's broken
uh let me get one question about the
lego movie okay you guys are the
romantic subplot of the lego movie and I
feel like it works really well I feel
like I feel like I was surprising how
much I wanted these two Lego characters
to get together and I'm wondering how
you found that chemistry through through
voice actor there's a directive here
directors in through the universe
something called the universe well I
asked for projected into history yeah
every night before he had to go to work
or go so they could have the sense of
energy of Hattie's and then they just
would not be they collided like this and
then they just in mesh anyway that works
for me well thank you guys so much for
this Thank You Martha conversation
[Music]